Hey everyone.  We are going to be taking a look at price discrimination and how that affects societal welfare whenever monopoly engages in it.
Let's go ahead and jump into it.
We're going to start with a price and quantity axis and then we're going to add in our demand curve.
And for simplicity, we're going to make the marginal cost curve equal the average cost curve and we're going to make it horizontal.
This gives us a price of $10.
Now we also have our marginal revenue curve which is downward sloping.
And let's add in a price that the monopoly charges.
Here we have $15.
Where marginal revenue equals marginal cost.
We have an output of 100.
Now what we want to do is analyze the welfare impacts of what we see.
First we have our consumer surplus, the area below the demand curve and above the price being charged.
This gives us a total of $250.
That goes back to the consumers.
Then we have our monopoly profit.
This is going to be whatever the monopoly charges minus its average cost times the quantity that it sells.
And this gives us $500.
Now we do have a problem and that's this area here.
This is a dead weight loss.
This is welfare that no one picks up.
It's an efficiency problem.
That is we don't gain all the efficiency in this market.
What's that about?
How can we correct this?
Simply put, all we need to do is have the monopoly charge where demand equals marginal cost.
This gives us a quantity of 200 units of output.
Now notice what happens.
All of these problems that we previously had go away.
This becomes all economic profit for the, for the monopoly.
So we get one, no consumer surplus, two, all profit for the monopoly and three, a completely efficient outcome.
Because there's no dead weight loss.
It all goes back to the monopoly.
Now this may not be a good thing to have because consumers don't get to enjoy any surplus.
Well, that might be your problem.
It's not what you like, it's the consumer.
But as far as efficiency goes, you can't do any better.
Now what we do end up with is $1,000 going to the monopoly.
This is what we call first degree or perfect price discrimination.
This is an instance in when the monopoly can figure out each person willingness to pay for that item and they charge each person that price.
So the monopoly can go in and erase all the consumer surplus and turn it into monopoly profit.
Let's look at a few other types of price discrimination.
Next we have second degree price price discrimination.
This is a quantity type price discrimination in which you get charged based on the amount that you consume.
If you look at your electricity bill and you look at your water bill, you have some base amount that you're going to be charged and then you get charged on the usage.
If your water bill is really high one month, that's because you use a lot more water and your water company is charging you more for that extra amount of water that you use.
If you go to a Costco or a Sam's Club, what you will see are more bulky items.
That is you can buy a whole lot more toilet paper or paper towels.
And you'll notice that the price per unit per roll is going to be less than if you went to a regular grocery store and purchased a four pack.
These are quantity discounts.
Then we also have our third degree or multi market price discrimination here.
The monopoly has to figure out that each consumer has some type of different price elasticity of demand.
And once it can determine that it charges those consumers different prices.
Look at movie tickets, look at the times of the day and the prices associated with those times.
Look at the age groups associated with with the movie ticket prices.
And what we find out is that the matinees are cheaper or yeah, are cheaper, the evenings are more expensive.
And that's because there's a differing price elasticity of demand for those groups of consumers.
How about discounts, coupons?
Yes, those are also a type of price discrimination because people who are going to use those have a different elasticity of demand than people who don't use those.
Therefore, what we can see is the monopoly goes in and they figure out the different price elasticities based off of who uses coupons.
And then you have your early bird buffets.
Here you have people going earlier out to eat and what they do is they get a cheaper meal than what you would get around these 6 and 7 o'clock hours.
We also have airfare here.
We end up with different prices based on when you go and purchase your ticket.
Notice we have this is Southwest and we have April 5th as a time that we're going to purchase something.
And when this video was made, what we are looking at is a time close to April 5th.
And then we look at June 7th, which is the same trip, Atlanta to San Francisco.
But notice the want to get away airfare differences.
$492 for the first flight versus $200 for the other flight that leaves on a much later date.
So what we see are people who need it now, they get charged much more than the people who need it later.
Business people who are going to a meeting that just got called.
They have to pay that price because they have to go to that business meeting and what we see is third degree price discrimination taking place.  All right.
That is it for price discrimination.
I hope you have enjoyed it and I'll catch you in our next one.